data science has completely transformed
all major business sectors including it
banking
Healthcare
Entertainment Sports and much more
in order to improve customer service and
their financial results businesses all
over the world have long gathered and
analyzed data about their customers the
global data science platform Market was
worth 3.93 billion US dollars in 2019
and 4.89 billion US dollars in 2020.
from 2020 to 2027 the market will be
expected to increase at a compound
annual growth rate of 26.9 percent due
to this huge usage and demand of data
science more and more folks are trying
to get into data science as a career
today in this video we will assist you
on how to switch career to data science
so stick with us till the end of this
video to understand each and every step
required to get into data science but
before moving on let me ask you a quick
question which of the following is the
most appropriate skill set for a data
scientist
probability and statistics machine
learning or deep learning data wrangling
or all of the above
please leave your answer in the comments
section below and stay tuned to get the
answer so first let's understand what
exactly data science is
given the enormous volumes of data being
generated today data science is one of
the most hotly contested topics in the
it Community data science methodologies
are being used by businesses to expand
their operations and it is used in a
wide variety of Industries including
marketing Healthcare finance and banking
data science is a field of study that
deals with massive amounts of data
utilizing contemporary Technologies to
uncover hidden patterns obtain valuable
information and make business decisions
building predictive models with data
science requires sophisticated machine
learning techniques like statistical
skills data visualization skills
analytical skills Etc one thing we've
observed about the jobs is the
similarity in how the job roles are
described you might be unable to
distinguish between the numerous data
science job profiles even though most
recruiters use the appropriate
description because of this you might
apply for the wrong jobs and miss the
good opportunities due to the confusion
between the work role and the job
description so let's understand each job
role in detail first up we have business
analyst business analysis is the process
of identifying a company's needs by
executing tasks and using specialized
approaches to acquire Insight from the
data
these experts analyze business processes
identify business requirements and give
data-driven reports and suggestions to
leaders and stakeholders in The Firm
next up there are data analysts the data
analyst is a specialist whose analysis
and problem-solving focus on data data
types and connections between data
elements in a business system
data analysts serve as a bridge between
data scientists and business analysts
they take the technical analyzes and
turn them into qualitative action items
coming to database oriented roles we
have database administrator
data like Financial records and customer
shipment history are stored and
organized using software by a database
administrator
a database administrator ensures that a
company's database and any related
applications run effectively and
functionally
next up we have data architect
data Architects are it Specialists who
utilize their knowledge of computer
science and database architecture to
assess and analyze an organization's
data infrastructure create future
database plans and put into practice
ways to store and manage data for both
businesses and their users
moving on to data engineer the
development deployment management and
optimization of the company's data
infrastructure and data pipelines is the
main emphasis of data Engineers by
assisting with data transport and
transformation for queries Engineers
assist data scientists and last but not
the least we have data scientists a data
scientist is someone who does
statistical analysis Data Mining and
data retrieval operations on large
amounts of data in order to find Trends
and information useful to an Enterprise
data scientists typically evaluate the
data in order to make the best business
decisions so which data science role do
you fancy let us know in the comments
each job role offers a unique chance to
develop a particular set of data skills
for example in business analytics you
will learn some technical skills such as
SQL Perl power bi and tableau some
interpersonal skills such as
presentation and negotiation skills
and some analytical skills such as Gap
analysis financial planning
documentation data reviewing and so on
then as a data analyst you learn how to
get insights convey important findings
and develop data-driven Solutions you
will learn python SQL and statistics
as a data scientist you'll be tasked
with real-world data science projects in
the field you'll learn how to run data
pipelines plan experiments and create
recommendation systems while developing
efficient machine learning models
as a data engineer you will work with
big data design data models construct
data lakes and warehouses and automate
data Pipelines
before we discuss how to switch from
another job profile to a data science
one consider subscribing to our Channel
we create informative videos like these
on a regular basis so hit the Bell icon
to not miss out on any new videos now
let's talk about switching from another
job profile to data science
to switch from some other job profile to
a data scientist profile you must
possess some good database skills in any
classical
rdbms including at least SQL programming
for example MySQL postgre SQL Oracle and
SQL Server you need to understand how to
use your mathematical background to
address actual business difficulties in
addition to all of this you'll need a
solid grasp of simulation statistical
inference and appropriate data
visualization
you can also study these topics
algorithms for machine learning linear
algebra and intermediate statistics and
probability
let's now look at the skills required to
become a data scientist
skills needed to become a data scientist
statistics and Mathematics deep learning
big data or data engineering
data visualization programming machine
learning
besides these you will require some tool
expertise SQL python Tableau XL so the
answer to the question at the beginning
of the video regarding the most
appropriate skill for a data scientist
is option D all of the above so these
were some of the skills that you need or
can learn to become a data scientist now
let's understand some ways to level up
your skills in data science how to level
up your skills Master relevant skills
the two most important programming
languages for data science are Python
and R give these two languages your
whole attention first the next is
mathematics
mathematics executing algorithms also
requires an understanding of probability
Theory and statistics moving on to
practice real world case studies
the case studies in data science center
on actual technical problems that
businesses are now experiencing having
experience resolving such case studies
will undoubtedly Aid you in developing
your career in the real world
next up we have maintain contact with
data science leaders it is always
thought to be a wise idea to seek
counsel from an expert who has
previously attained Mastery in the field
of data science you may do it by
connecting with data science experts via
websites and services like LinkedIn
another fantastic strategy for achieving
your organization's objective is to
enroll in a data science program to
reinvent tomorrow's Enterprises now
let's understand about the networking
you need to create which will help you
in switching your career to data science
so first we have Meetup and conferences
meetups and conferences are excellent
locations to network with other aspiring
data scientists you may meet established
data scientists at some of these events
network with them and even learn about
unannounced job openings
next up we have knowledge Discovery in
data science a major data science
conference is called knowledge Discovery
in data science it is also a group that
works to promote the study and teaching
of the science behind data science and
at last but not least we have LinkedIn
you can find some profiles of
established data scientists who work at
organizations that are presently hiring
and who appear to share your technical
interests more than just the fact that
you both work in data science you can
uncover things that you have in common
with them so these were some ways to
help you switch your career to data
science a variety of job opportunities
will become open to you once you have
mastered these skills so which profile
are you targeting
now that you have every detail let us
know in the comments below alright guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video please
give it a thumbs up I hope it really
helped you all thanks for watching stay
safe and keep learning
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here